[Musik]
corona nachgehakt
die zahl der infizierten in deutschland
steigt mit beunruhigenden tempo
gleichzeitig gibt es glücklicherweise
keinen anstieg bei den intensivpatienten
und den toten wie also sollten wir die
vierte welle bekämpfen dazu begrüße ich
in berlin den virologen und
epidemiologen professor klaus stöhr
klaus stöhr war 15 jahre lang bei der
weltgesundheitsorganisation whu als
leiter des influenza programms und als
koordinator der sars forschung herzlich
willkommen bei koronar nachgehakt schön
montag herrschte die inzidenz steigt wir
erleben eine verdopplung in wenigen
tagen wie gefährlich ist diese situation
also jetzt erstmal der richtig dass man
die welle incident sich anschaut
allerdings ist sie eine einmischung aus
verschiedenen parametern man sieht ja
jetzt wie sie es schon in der einleitung
sagten dass vor allen dingen die zahlen
bei den jüngeren sehr stark nach oben
gehen die höchste zunahme bei den 20 bis
24 jährigen während bei den über 50 und
60 jährigen eigentlich die situation der
stabiles in tänzen von 5 bis 7 also muss
man die instanz aufteilen in der
altersgruppen spezifische incident dann
ist sie immer noch hilfreich und
gemeinsam mit den
krankenhauseinweisungen mit den
bewegungen aus den intensivstationen
könnten dass die parameter seien um das
hat natürlich die krankheitslast
abzubilden zahlen allein je nach oben
gehen helfen nicht eine differenzierte
bekämpfung zu organisieren heißt denn
dass die gegenwärtige situation ist
harmlos weil die inzidenz bei den
älteren den gefährdeten nicht dramatisch
anstalt also harmlos ist die inzidenz
ich habe dass die situation jetzt nicht
weil natürlich die doch schwer schwere
winterwetter noch bevorsteht aber
gegenwärtig sehen wir keine zunahme
dramatische zunahme auf den
intensivstationen wir denen die
hospitalisierung traten auf niedrigem
niveau was wir sehen ist es eine zunahme
an asymptomatischen jugendlichen der
erkranken oder leicht erkrankten
mittelalten
personen und das muss man natürlich
beobachten aber die krankheit last muss
ja gemessen werden also wie schwer sind
die erkrankungen wie viele personen
kommen auf die intensivstation in die
krankenhäuser und da muss man ansetzen
das hätte man von anfang an eigentlich
seit dem beginn der pandemie auf dieser
schweren erkrankungen konzentriert und
ohne natürlich die anderen aus dem
blickfeld zu verlieren unter anderem
baden württemberg und nordrhein
westfalen haben neue corona verordnungen
erlassen da spielt die inzidenz kaum
mehr eine rolle ab 35 gilt 3g in
innenräumen ansonsten kommt die inzidenz
nicht vor ist das richtig das
reflektiert ja eigentlich die den die
ersten schritte in richtung normalität
bei einem normalen
atemwegsinfektionen wie influenza dino
viren mehta promovieren fahrer empören
sollte ein auto mit höheren da gibt es
ja viele da schaut man ja auch nicht
danach wie viele junge menschen mal
nicht im in zur schule gehen oder wenn
jemand mal zwei tage zu hause ist und
fragt man sich wie viele personen werden
in die hospitäler eingewiesen und so
macht man jetzt in baden württemberg
übrigens auch in anderen ländern in
sachsen denkt man darüber nach oder hat
ja schon in der verordnung aufgelegt in
schleswig holstein berlin gibt es eine
ampelregelung also langsam setzt sich
der vorstand der four staatsverständnis
durch das man jetzt bevor der herbst
beginnt eine neue strategie fahren muss
ansonsten wenn man die inzidenz nimmt
hat man im herbst ruckzuck 100 200 oder
500 er ins elend macht die geschäfte zu
bei gleichzeitiger normaler belastung in
den intensivstationen und das kann ja
nicht der sinn der sache sein jetzt hat
das er ja immer gesagt wir brauchen die
inzidenz weil das der einzige
verlässliche frühindikator ist
die internet ist ein frühindikator aber
die sollte altersgruppen spezifisch sein
wenn tatsächlich jetzt viele über 50 60
jährige nun schon geimpft sind krank
werden dann ist das ein gutes zeichen
dafür dass höchstwahrscheinlich bald in
den intensivstationen und krankenhäuser
der druck zunimmt das muss man genau
beachten aber es ist tatsächlich so wenn
jetzt tatsächlich mehr jugendliche
erkrankt durch die testung in den
schulen noch asymptomatischen kinder
sehen ist das relevant
sicherlich relevant deswegen weil man
sich fragen muss wie viele sind dann
schon geimpft aber die eigentliche
bedeutung haben natürlich die schweren
erkrankungen bei den über 50 und 60
jahren da liegen ja auch 99 prozent der
todesfälle also darauf muss man sich
konzentrieren aber wie gesagt ohne die
anderen aus dem auge zu verlieren
herdenimmunität ist das große ziel ist
das überhaupt erreichbar
ja die ist der begriff herdenimmunität
verwendet man bei erregern in die man
ausrotten kann der begriff bei den
atemwegserkrankungen passt einfach nicht
bei herren immunisiert bedeutet ich
schaffe tatsächlich teile der herde die
dann auch vollständig immun sind die
kein virus mehr ausscheiden die dich
nicht mehr infizieren können und dann
rettet man in der regel aus dass wir bei
wacken hat mich passieren auch bei den
anderen 200 atemwegserkrankungen was
richtig es ist dass man eine sehr hohe
immun schwelle erreichen möchte desto
mehr personen vor dem herbst geimpft
sind desto schwächer oder nicht so stark
wird die winter welle ausfallen aber der
begriff herdenimmunität passt hier
leider nicht hinein und es ist ja nicht
der einzige begriff der in der
krisenkommunikation
schlecht oder völlig falsch verwendet
wurde auch andere mythen existierende
aber noch der impfstoff soll
hundertprozentigen schutz geben man
wundert sich dass geimpfte personen
virus ausscheiden sagt sie sich re
infizieren können das sind alles dinge
die hat man glaube ich in der
krisenkommunikation nicht sehr gut
rübergebracht manche experten empfehlen
jetzt hohe infektionszahlen bei jungen
und gesunden bewusst zuzulassen um am
ende so die pandemie zu bekämpfen ist
das eine sinnvolle strategie oder
gefährlich natürlich ist das eine sache
die muss man sich genau anschauen
die frage für mich ist das ende der
pandemie am anfang im auge zu haben und
wenn du am ende der pandemie klar ist
dass ich bestimmte altersgruppen nicht
impfen kann und das sind
höchstwahrscheinlich die unter
zwölfjährigen oder bestimmte nicht im
will ich sehen dann muss man davon
ausgehen dass man die mit der impfung
nicht erreichen und dann werden die sich
irgendwie infizieren und desto weniger
menschen jetzt im sommer sich infizieren
von den impfwilligen und von denen die
man nicht impfen kann desto mehr werden
die von dem herbst also krank werden
deswegen ist es auf der eintragen
richtig zu sich dazu überlegen genau
darin man davon ist es dann aus ihrer
sicht falsch ganze schulklassen in
quarantäne zu schicken wenn sich da
einer oder eine infiziert das aus
mehreren gründen eigentlich falsch
erstens weil die daten ja klar belegen
ist gibt ja gute studien zum beispiel
aus hessen dass die anzahl der kontakt
kinder in den schulen von einem index
fall außerordentlich kleines also man
hier kann man beim test nur der
kontaktperson schon unheimlich viel
machen das ganze klassen in die
quarantäne schicken es geht völlig über
das ziel hinaus sehr guten daten da die
werden jetzt auch publiziert anfang
september also aus der richtung ist
schon falsch aber im letzten jahr hätte
man sich schon überlegen sollen schaffen
wir es tatsächlich die infektion
wegzuhalten von den kindern unter 12
jahren was bedeutet dass in der
konsequenz lohnt es sich deswegen die
schulen und kindergärten so zu schließen
denn letztendlich kann es gut sein sehr
wahrscheinlich dass am ende der pandemie
die unter zwölfjährigen kein impfstoff
sehen und sich höchstwahrscheinlich
natürlich infizieren werden von anfang
an war in dieser pandemie die richtige
strategie umstritten deswegen würde ich
gerne mit ihnen mal zusammen einen blick
ins ausland wagen was können wir denn
vielleicht von anderen ländern lernen
also erstmal hätte man sehr viel von
sich selbst lernen können der
pandemieplan didas ag entwickelt hat und
1916 2016 und 17 auch auf den neuesten
stand gebracht hat da hätte man schon
viel daraus lernen können zum beispiel
auch ob man die schulen und kindergärten
schließt was man als altersspezifische
in stents verwendet wie man die
krankheitslast mit mist wie auch gute
kommunikations komponenten andere länder
haben einiges besser gemacht
das ist natürlich nicht so dass sie
alles richtig gemacht haben in der
schweiz hat man nach anfänglichen
schulschließungen seit mai letzten
jahres die schulen nicht mehr
geschlossen die masten pflicht hat dort
auch praktisch nicht existiert in
einigen kantonen schon in frankreich hat
man das in ähnliche strategie gefahren
und er hat man unter großen
große akzeptanz auch sehr hoher
instanzen die schulen durchgehend offen
gelegt gehalten in dänemark hat man eine
sehr restriktive strategie gefahren von
anfang an er hat versucht durch
intensives testen die inzidenz niedrig
zu halten insgesamt in der bevölkerung
und jetzt sagt man in dänemark wir
werden am ersten oktober öffnen wir
müssen zur normalität zurück und der
schritt richtung normalität heißt
natürlich dann auch infektionen zu
lassen bei denen die eben nicht immer
willig sind oder die wir nicht impfen
können da gibt es ja auch gar keine
andere alternative und in england hat
man den radikalen weg gewählt zur
normalität meines erachtens etwas früh
weil noch nicht alle ins angebot hatten
das hätte man meines erachtens abwarten
sollen aber dann sagt mir wir müssen der
realität ins auge schauen in zukunft
wird niemand mehr fragen hast du einen
impfpass wenn man dem ins restaurant
gehen will da wird auch niemand mehr
fragen bist du dein geimpft und wie
lange es das schon her und hast du deine
mutter schon bekommen wir wissen dass in
zukunft sich alle infizieren werden auch
die geimpften wir wissen dass jeder der
sich infiziert geimpft oder infiziert
auch virus ausscheidet und dass wir mit
dieser situation leben müssen weil die
re infektionen relativ mild ausfallen
und die kinder wie bei allen anderen
atemwegserkrankungen auch ausnahmslos
werden sich bis zum alter von zwölf bis
18 jahren
natürlich infizieren auch zum teil mit
schweren erkrankungen den usa hat man
sich deswegen entschloss aber wenig
verstehen das sollten wir zulassen dass
die kinder sich in der masse infizieren
ja das ist keine frage dass wir das
zulassen sollen das ist die akzeptierte
verhältnismäßige reaktion die in den
letzten jahrzehnten
so umgesetzt wurde in deutschland und
weltweit da hat niemand die frage
gestellt von den über 200 existierenden
atemwegserkrankung müssen wollen können
wir die kinder impfen ist das
verhältnismässig ist das jetzt
durchseuchung ist das ethisch das war
die in der gesellschaft querbeet
akzeptierte meinung gewesen ein fall den
sie angesprochen haben finde ich sehr
interessant das ist die schweiz die
schweiz hat die schulen fast die ganze
zeit offen gelassen auch die hotels sehr
lange offen gehalten und hat trotzdem
eine vergleichbare incidents und
vergleichbar viele tote pro kopf der
bevölkerung wie deutschland wie haben
sie das gemacht in der schweiz hier hat
man hat eben sehr
restriktiv auch versucht die melde
inzidenz diese querschnitte sie dann auf
einem akzeptablen niveau zu halten was
ich gesagt habe es dafür man im winter
die inzidenz nicht unter 50 bekommt ohne
druck und dann kann man es nicht halten
haben die anderen länder auch
offensichtlich begriffen hat man unser
schweiz gesagt okay wir akzeptieren
inzidenz von 250 von 150 wir können dann
einigermaßen das leben warm laufen
lassen wir haben auch die haben auch die
geschäfte geschlossen hat eine gewisse
zeit man hat auch sehr restriktiv was
die öffentliche verkehrsmittel
kontakt beschränkungen umgesetzt aber
wenn es dann wieder der druck nach lyss
hat man auch wieder geöffnet und das ist
ja eben genau das was man glaube ich
jetzt in deutschland was ich dort
vermisse die niedrigste incidents in
deutschland europaweit und gleichzeitig
bewegt man sich auf die winterweide zu
und wenn man jetzt die fälle die man
sowieso im winter nicht verhindern kann
jetzt nicht zulässt wird man die
winterwelt besonders stark machen das
ist gar keine frage denn irgendwann
waren die leute die sich jetzt nicht
infizieren können die im unwillig sind
oder wo es keinen impfstoff gibt die
werden sich dann infizieren und die
schweizer haben das eigentlich mit einer
sehr guten balance hinbekommen dass sie
das sehen wir an den zahlen armin
laschet und markus söder haben
versprochen es gibt wird keinen weiteren
lockdown mehr geben ist so ein
versprechen
realistisch und überhaupt durchhaltbar
ja das ist die frage wo man dann die
parameter ansetzt an dem man reagiert
ich habe ja schon immer gesagt wir
brauchen einen stufenplan in deutschland
der vorhersagbaren maßnahmen mit
bestimmten parametern verbindet also ob
man vielleicht sagt die
altersspezifische inzidenz bei den über
50 jährigen
sollte vielleicht nicht 75 oder 100
übersteigen die inzidenz in den unteren
altersgruppen können höher sein die
intensivstationen an die
hospitalisierung skate und dann hat man
vorhersagbare maßnahmen gekoppelt an
diese
parameter das brauchen wir jetzt denn
ich bin mir sicher dass im herbst die
situation sich wieder dramatisch
verschärfen wird die instanzen werden
stark zunehmen wir haben gegenwärtig
zwischen
4,6 und 6 millionen über 60 jährigen
noch nicht geimpft ich hoffe bei dem
jetzigen im fortschritt könnten das
immerhin noch 10 millionen mehr sein
querbeet durch die gesamte gesellschaft
pro monat das würde natürlich schon
unterschied machen aber in lockdown
glaube ich sollte man nicht mehr machen
solange alle ein imker angebot bekommen
haben dann haben die leute sich
entschieden zwischen impfungen oder
infektionen und werde ich für die
infektion entschieden hat ist es dann
auch sehr schwierig wenn man impfen
willig ist dann muss man
höchstwahrscheinlich auch die
konsequenzen tragen für den die die man
nicht im von kannte für die unter
zwölfjährigen wird die infektion sowie
in den nächsten jahren jahrzehnten
vielleicht jahrhunderten
natürlich erfolgen da es gibt leider
kein impfstoff für diese altersgruppe
das risiko nutzen verhältnis hat aber
ich glaube so ein stufenplan würde
helfen wenn es hat die
dänen haben damals gesagt die haben
gesagt die inzidenz über 500 ist in den
gemeinden und über 1000 in der stadt
dann müssen wir das unternehmen da hat
man also eine einfache zielmarke gesetzt
denn dann wird es auch mit den
krankenhäusern eben dramatisch aber in
deutschland ja es gibt halt keine keinen
plan und ich kann mir auch nicht
verstehen dass man jetzt wieder sagt wir
können keine vorhersage treffen weil wir
nicht wissen wie der herbst wird man
kann aber drei szenarien erarbeiten
nicht so schlimm mittel schlimm ganz
schlimm und dann die maßnahmen dazu und
dann kann man die diskutieren und dann
auch die rechtlichen die
wirtschaftlichen die freiheitlichen und
die gesundheitlichen auswirkungen
evaluieren und dann hat man was auf dem
tisch bevor der herbst beginnt so ein
plan muss jetzt auf den tisch das war
corinna nachgehakt heute mit professor
klaus stöhr herzlichen dank
sie und ihnen liebe zu schauen liebe
zuschauer bleiben sie gesund und vielen
dank für ihr interesse
[Musik]